Le 26 juin, enfin, l'infanterie américaine
pénètre dans les faubourgs de Cherbourg.
Ce même jour, devant une presse
qu'il ne semble guère apprécier,
le général von Schlieben, commandant de la garnison,
se rend.
Si ce colosse sait s'essuyer les pieds
devant son vainqueur, le jeune général Collins.
L'allemand s'assoit aussi sur son serment
fait à Hitler.
De préférer la mort à une honteuse reddition.
Comble de flétrissure, Schlieben s'est soumis
avant même ces hommes,
qui le lendemain se rendent à leur tour.
Les Américains ne sont pas toujours des tendres,
ce qui peut se comprendre.
Depuis le jour J, ils ont déjà perdu 22 000 hommes.
À voir la moyenne d'âge des prisonniers
vieux ou très jeunes,
on constate le délabrement de la Wehrmacht.
Dont les troupes les plus aguerries
sont surtout mobilisées à l'Est,
pour combattre l'Armée rouge.
36 000 prisonniers à Cherbourg.
Chiffre énorme au regard
de ce que peut capter une caméra.
Sauf qu'elle aussi, parfois,
étonne et frappe.
Avec la prise de Cherbourg s'écroule l'une
des dernières pièces du mythique mur de l'Atlantique.
Même si, contrairement à leurs hommes,
une certaine morgue se lit toujours
sur le visage des officiers faits prisonniers.
Mais peut-être aussi une certaine honte.
Après Cherbourg, Hitler procède
à une reprise en main de l'armée allemande
sur le front Ouest.
Il a limogé von Runstedt
qui avait suggéré de faire la paix
et la remplacer par Von Kluge, plus docile.
Rommel, accablé par le jusqu'auboutisme
du Führer, lui sait qu'il ne reste au mieux
qu'à retarder le désastre.
Eisenhower, de son côté, est aussi inquiet.
Certes, les Américains ont conquis Cherbourg,
mais Montgomery n'a toujours pas pris Caen,
à partir de laquelle il devait
percer les lignes allemandes.
Installés à l'intérieur des terres.
La Wehrmacht a l'avantage de l'espace
avec les possibilités de ravitaillement
et de renforts qu'elle confère.
Alors que les alliés restent toujours enfermés
le long des côtes de la Manche.
Dès lors, les Américains n'ont d'autre choix
que de tenter de percer le front ennemi
dans le Cotentin.
Pas facile à faire dans une région de bocage
où les haies avantagent la défense.
Voir sans être vu.
Un atout pour l'ennemi dans cette bataille
à laquelle les boys ne sont pas préparés.
Dans ce labyrinthe en damier, quelques combattants
résolus peuvent arrêter un bataillon.
Mais quand ils doivent céder un de ces champs carrés,
il suffit qu'ils reviennent ensuite par les côtés.
Les chars américains obligés d'emprunter les routes
et les chemins sont alors des cibles faciles.
Ils le sont encore quand ils doivent franchir
les levers de terre à la base des haies
et qu'ils offrent aux ennemis
leur ventre dépourvu de blindage.
Bilan de ces pièges,
des milliers de GI tués
et une percée ratée dans ce maudit bocage.
The God them countries.
Une saleté de pays.
Cette fois, les Anglais,
devant les difficultés des Américains,
se doivent d'en finir rapidement avec Caen.
Montgomery décide enfin d'employer les grands moyens.
Il a demandé le renfort de l'aviation.
Plus de 2 500 tonnes de bombes
sont déversées sur la ville.
Certains avancent, d'autres partent.
À quoi bon se regarder ?
C'est comme ça !
Après 2 jours de combats acharnés,
115 000 Anglais pénètrent à l'Est de la ville,
aux trois quarts détruite.
Le 13 juillet, Montgomery arrive à son tour.
Il lui aura fallu plus d'un mois pour s'emparer
d'une partie de Caen
qu'il espérait prendre dès le premier jour
et d'où devait partir la percée des Alliés.
Décidément, au royaume des aveugles,
les borgnes sont rois.
Les habitants ont beau hisser
le drapeau à Croix de Lorraine,
seule une partie de la ville est prise.
Ce qui n'empêche pas la propagande anglaise
de faire croire qu'entre habitants
de la ville aux 100 clochers et soldats britanniques,
on trinque.
Au revoir et merci encore.
Je vous en prie.
Tout le plaisir est pour moi.
Pareil bombardement et leurs 2 000 morts,
alors même que les défenses allemandes
étaient situés hors de la ville.
Était-il nécessaire ?
Le débat encore aujourd'hui reste ouvert.
Chacun réagit comme il peut.
Qui étais-tu, toi, l'Allemand, jouant au même moment
de l'orgue dans cette église normande en ruine ?
Un fou ?
Un salaud de boche ?
Un Allemand mélomane ?
Ou un simple soldat perdu de Hitler,
désormais dépassé par le délire de son chef
et qui essaie d'oublier cette atmosphère
de fin du monde.